It's Game one of the Western Conference Finals the Golden State Warriors the San Antonio Spurs
Happy heavy underdog
Leonard with the ball drives and finishes
San Antonio won 14, Leonard drives
muscles way inside of scoffers
letter tips away trying to hide
But eight minutes left to go in the third quarter, why do is out of the game? It's an opportunity
Walk up on day. He took away that baby
I think the NBA's gotta cool that condition this Coast look a guy has to have space to come down which pointers much today
46 to 22 was the run that was gone on from them. San Antonio couldn't get anything done
If I'm the Spurs when you don't have your star that's a big concern
As a teammate the atmosphere that they have with the Spurs and their team chemistry
What it's been for so long for him to not be a game. That's my pop will punish him for that
I'll be surprised if he returns the season
This year they have not been as dominant as they have been in the past three or four seasons
your legs are not hurting that bad I go for the blue gets it right here and
Santa and clap for your team
Tonie park, he's not moving here senatorial pulsing
Same kind of injury I might was a hundred times worse. It starts to make us think about how severe this play
Is super reporters are reporting like a wild under he wants out. He wants out of San Antonio
he didn't like what was going on in how they handled his injury in San Antonio and
He wants to go. Well as you all know, that's why you're here
traders been made
Hawaiian daddy moving on to Toronto and
My DeRozan an octave hurdle coming to San Antonio
And taking a chance of a guy who has told you very specifically they did not want to be traded to Toronto
Can you keep waddling in Toronto? You're getting a arguably one of the top five powers of the NBA
You look at that last you say wow
This Eastern Conference could be wide open maybe this team to get back to the top of them
Hopefully this gonna elevate us as much as we want, you know, when the blind games leaving the eat
Then they feel on the paper to come out of it, but in my estimation
Thailand is the best
defenders
Investment, I mean daga is incredible. If you ask the superstars in our league, they may not say it publicly, but I guarantee
None of them like me by koala. He is that much of an impact on the game
Thank you lady I just feel like he's gonna do the Paladins he has to go and impose Kawhi Leonard to everything
And says anything, but he doesn't bad day
Like this, you know, you can do it on both ends of the floor and serve others
They make a run to the Eastern Conference Finals or even the NBA Finals why I really have to think twice about do I really
Want to leave here, I know la is real sunny, but the six that something for me
It's easy to forget how good quiet learned it was. He was a Finals MVP as well. That's not me
This is the reason why he was brought here everybody that question why did booth happen or why a possible rental of a Kawhi Leonard?
This is the reason why
Why am be low for him took over the basketball game? Nathan a nice job Toronto? Just grinding this one out. Really?
just trying to play as perfect as possibly just
into us early
When you look at his ability to store he's as efficient is almost anybody else reserving the top super sizing lightly
He's the player of the caliber tech get you over to home and that's exactly what happened. I
Got a really good plan get us baskets when you need them
if they do get to the NBA Finals
Very silly for me to say that the Raptors have no chance to resign Kawhi Leonard
Is Yanis the new LeBron into East Yanis is on his way I think the Toronto Raptors coach
It has to come down today just gotta compete. Well, the benches been basically destroyed by Milwaukee's bench. You don't want to go down 3-0
just gonna win home you gave up your best player want to be the guys team all he said that
And you look at the office and when you look at co-op the difference is we shot making the ability of
Belial on earth and what opens up think about the gamble that Mossad Yuri looks like it's played out pretty well
Toronto Raptors who will be the first team to host an NBA Finals outside the United States
On the upcoming challenge that the defending champion warriors will present like you decide in a Champions
The mental focus and
Congratulations Kauai go celebrate they got hard and they reckon
Kawai has led them somewhere. They've never been before they have a great chance to win this series
We're not done yet man, you gotta step on that's the time we got a fella